how many times per week can a man cry
my negative one
is how many how many times have times
can your man cry
I think it depends like you say first
exactly imagine he's lost someone
important to him like cry as much as you
want you have to get it out but if it's
like like you said like just give us a
blunt just give us a blunt on his number
but what's more attractive a man that
can like hold it together and be strong
or a man that's like blubbering on the
floor like crying for like weeks being
vulnerable and crying
but but you date the ass
and if he comes home and he's like so
you annoyed me at work and started like
I'm beautiful that's an ick yeah okay
okay
he loses someone close to him he's
crying every day yeah for two three
weeks straight every single day you're
you're you're just fine because I've
done the same thing for two years yeah
mature girls so like but you're equally
you're equally attractive
through him the same no but I mean
there's a way to deal with that because
if I I'm there for you so I'm gonna help
you get up yeah that's a long time yeah
I'm gonna have to I'm gonna have to step
in now because I've allowed you one two
he's all right but no no we need to work
on this let's let's even if if I was a
girl even I'd be like listen bro like
you need to fix up like
time to move like how's your time to
like you know cry and yeah you're still
going
we're gonna learn how to deal with this
because there's no way I'm gonna watch
different ways of dealing with it like
whether that's crying for weeks on end
or kind of like getting back to work
because everyone's doing it but like
there's a certain time where it's like
yo like like you're living like that the
person's gonna be loved and remembered
you're going to go put flowers in the
grave and light a candle and you know
just chill there and talk to that grave
you know I mean actually yeah but like
life goes on like you gotta like move
past that no matter obviously it's going
to be hard but yeah but like the way you
want to do it I don't think there's I
don't think there's a time limit on that
like for example my friend lost his mum
um he lost his dad when he was much
younger when he was a child and then he
lost his mom and he's his only only
child like if he wanted to cry for a
whole year I get it because that was the
only person you were close to like he
has family that uncles and aunties and
stuff yeah but like we get it yeah
I think girls get it but we're just not
attracted to it yeah I was gonna say
your question was are you are you more
attracted to someone who's gonna deal
with it straight away so I'll go in gym
like like deal with it that way it's
gonna
okay like cry a little bit but then
you're not gonna be attracted to someone
that's you're gonna be more attracted to
someone who's like wow they're going out
they're they're doing like I don't know
like charity marathons for whatever or
they're like they're doing something
active you know to like get over it
okay and how you're dealing with it
she's like I get that but she's saying
what's more attractive
no I think it depends on if
crying every day every day for however
however long is fine
if you're not moping about if you're
still proactive so if you're still
proactive you're still doing what he
needs to do but every now and again you
know he'll catch himself thinking about
the person you lost and he cries that's
perfectly fine but if he's just doing
nothing and dedicating his you know
every week and hour to just crying and
not yeah being motivated and I can
completely understand that you know that
being a turn off but I feel like I'm not
a woman but I feel like a woman can
still find a guy attractive if he's
crying every day but still showing a
masculine yeah I just I think and this
is bad this is bad but it's just honest
like I think a woman can understand yeah
but I don't think a girl really is going
to want to screw you after she's seen
you crying I just don't think we're
turned on bring them bring them down a
bit as well if they're trying to always
cheer you up yeah it's gonna bring you
down as well a little bit yeah and like
it's that it's not fun I don't enjoy
this it's just I just think it's how
we're wired yeah like we want we want
the guy like the the men I respect the
most in my life like when I think of
them they don't cry yeah like my dad
I've seen him cry like twice there's no
one I respect more than my dad
and every time like I've seen him yeah
twice in my life and it's much better to
like I think have like strong masculine
presence and then occasionally like when
you when if that happens now and then
it's like rather than someone that's
blubbering or every every time something
goes wrong they're blubbering because
how am I supposed to trust you if you're
like in your feminine and like every
time something goes wrong
I guess it depends it depends on the
frequency yeah yeah if if it's all the
time it's a bit
I feel like for that sort of reason as
well that's why like a lot of men they
go there's a lot more men that um commit
suicide than females yeah I think
it's it's got a lot to do with that as
well because they don't want to seen be
seen vulnerable by their partner or they
don't wanna
show emotions so
they let it build up by trying to be
active or do whatever rather than just
let out yeah it builds up mentally and
then they end up like killing themselves
or you know being depressed or like
gets worse
so I feel like women women can level out
they can cry wherever they can talk talk
or whatever about their problems
and I feel like it can get dealt with
better because
um they're allowed to they're allowed to
by Society basically so yeah well I
think I think men should be able to like
cry and be emotional I just think they
should be able to they should do it to
other men
you can call it the worst but it's
honest like I'm just being honest like
your girl is not going to respect you
like every study that's ever studied
this ever has has has come to the
conclusion that if the girl if if the
guy cries in front of the girl she does
not respect you the same and so like I
could lie like I could lie to you and
say oh and like pretend I'm different
and but I'm like being honest like I I
don't think it's wise to cry in front of
your girl all the time like she's not I
mean
yeah like I don't know like how often
you guys cry oh yeah let me know can't
actually I've not cried in a minute
I've not cried in a minute there's
nothing the Lord no no I actually like
that like the last time I've cried I
remember specifically that was when my
great grandma passed away but the way I
cried it was like it was one of those
things where I walked in yeah and I saw
her like in the casket and stuff like
that and then I just stayed there for a
minute and then I didn't like cry but it
was automatic like my tears just started
pouring out so I'm just there with the
most straightest face and like just yeah
it's like it's like you know he's trying
to hold like you've been trying to be
gangster and be like
you know
yeah
and that was like
six years ago
I'm gonna read the super chats really
quick okay
um my favorite donut sentience fifty
dollars come on girl come on my God
he's back I like it okay okay um again
guys all of these super chats are going
towards another camera I'm trying to get
angle here angle here if we raise 500 or
in the Stream I think I want to say I'm
sorry I'm ballparking I don't know the
exact number but it's like around 500
I'm trying to get before the end of the
month so we can afford